من هو اللاعب الكوري الذي يحمل رقم تسعه
واضطر الى اغلاق هاتفه بسبب طلبات الزواج
المستمره من الفتيات العربيات والكوريات
[موسيقى]
اللاعب منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه البالغه من
العمر 24 عاما اسرى قلوب المعجبه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد مباراه غانا
وكوريا الجنوبيه في مونديال قطر
[موسيقى]
بينما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام اجنبيه
بعد ان تفجر بسبب طلبات الزواج المستمره
من المعجبات
[موسيقى]
كما تصدر اللاعب سونج وسائل الاعلام كوريا
بخبر عن علاقته مع احدى الفنانات الكوريه
[موسيقى]
كان يمتلك في حسابه 20 الف متابع ليرتفع
ذلك الرقم لحوالي مليونين متابع في ليله
وضحاها الاسماء بعد ان سجل ثنائيه ضد غانا
ساهمت في صعود المنتخب الكوري الى الدوره
السادسه عشر ونجح الفريق ايضا بالتغلب على
البرتغال بهدفين مقابل هدف
[موسيقى]